use your aggressive feelings boy let the
hate flow through you so I was not sure
that I was gonna do a follow-up video in
regards to Star Wars cuz honestly I kind
of I want to stop thinking about it I've
have a I've had a hard time doing that
I've been thinking about the movie
almost continuously since I saw it no I
haven't seen it a second time I don't
plan to because while I still stand by
my original review and the fact that
when it is good it is great I like the
movie less overall the more that I think
about it now there's still something a
little bit odd going on which is that
I'm seeing the conversation happen with
people who are claiming that the movie
is bad or it's terrible it's greater
it's this sorts that and a lot of the
issues that people seem to have are
actually not the ones that I have
alright guys I need to say this right
now at the front end spoilers spoilers
spoilers throughout this whole thing
alright good good a lot of my issues are
with the movie are structural in nature
both within the the film itself and in
terms of its place in the overall Star
Wars story I have way less problems with
the thematic elements that a lot of
people seem to take issue with which you
know that's more things like the nature
of Rey and some things that happen you
know what is implied where things might
be going in the future people seem to
and some of the stuff with Luke people
seem to have big thumb attic fundamental
issues with that I don't most my issues
or execution most of the concepts going
on in this movie I am perfectly okay
with or even really like but I still
don't like the movie so I kind of want
to talk about the divide that's
happening and it's a divided you know
you could say it's between audiences and
critics kind of depends on where you go
because I mean you can go to Rotten
Tomatoes and the audience score is under
60% which basically means it has a
glowing critics score and a rotten
audience score but different sources are
giving it different things cinema scores
is something else
there's some other sites that have the
different things so I'm this is not a
hard data thing when I say there's a
divide I'm I'm going largely or
anecdotally I'm going off what I've been
watching going on over the last few days
in my own comment section and also you
know sort of gauging off of the kinds of
reviewers and and folks who I normally
follow and it's been interesting night I
just I have some thoughts about why the
divide happened because I can see the
validity and a lot of the arguments that
I actually have seen made by people who
not only like the movie but have put out
a digital material since kind of the
backlash has happened defending you know
the various aspects of the movie
including from people who I tend to
agree with often and who honestly make
good arguments but I still don't agree I
still think there's a lot of really big
issues with this and honestly uh
ultimately the big problems with this
movie are more to do with its greater
context and what has gone on in general
around Star Wars and less so with the
movie itself if you were to truly
restrict issues with just the film set
everything else to decide and basically
deal with it in a vacuum really the only
part is the middle act is a little bit
too leisurely paced and the stakes feel
a little bit off but it opens well it
ends well the characters are strong the
themes are clear there isn't a heck of a
lot that's wrong will they take it as a
film completely unto itself it's within
the greater context of Star Wars that
things start to fall apart which I think
might be part of the reason that critics
are being much more favorable to it than
audience and certainly fans are because
I think it is more common for critics to
try and look at the thing in isolation
and deal with it completely as its own
thing and and to not pull in as much
baggage that we as fans tend to do
either because you know it's just their
job to review every movie and they may
not be inherent fans of it so they need
to basically take it as its own film or
even if they are fans you
there's the there's basically the
critical objective ideal you know trying
not to bring too much of your own
baggage in an analysis which I'm not
sure I agree with in the first place but
is a thing that happens and there's a
lot of critics who may even be fans but
aren't trying to let that sway their
opinion excessively so I think that's
part of the divide I think the other
thing is I see a lot of people who
really like the movie basically sort of
praising the new direction that Star
Wars is going in what this indicates for
that and in and of itself I agree with
that but again I put everything into
context and that's where it starts not
working so I'm gonna I'm gonna try and
keep this focused and you know as best
as me and my rambling Randy wake and
stay on top I can stay focused but I'm
gonna try and deal with specific things
and then get to an overall point if I
can pull it off we'll see let's start
with Snoke
we basically not only don't get answers
about him
but the fact that he is killed off
removes the need to ever give us answers
about this and another thing I'm not
gonna deal with here is I am NOT gonna
be dealing with any theories that have
anything to do with this whole notion of
oh I bet it's a double deal secret
reveal and he'll come back and he'll
does it and Ray will really have parents
who met no no there's nothing here to
indicate that that is gonna be the case
it's not impossible but even if they do
that if they yank it back again in
Episode nine that's gonna be its own
thing because they they will have a
completely incongruent trilogy of new
films but again I'm not gonna deal with
that because that's all speculative but
I want to deal with a movie that we
actually have and in terms of the movie
we have we didn't get answers and the
fact that he dies removes the impetus
for us to ever get answers about Snoke
now I've seen the argument made that
Snoke was never meant to be a mystery in
the first place in the force awakens and
that the film itself doesn't really
build him up as a mystery pointing to
such things as the fact that there
aren't any characters who are asking
questions about we need to find out the
secrets of snow which would have been
your big clue in that it was gonna
actually be a part of the narrative that
this stuff was uncovered
and there's a certain validity to that
and I what I will grant is I think fans
made a little bit of a mountain out of a
molehill just you know two years worth
of speculation I think we did make more
out of the idea of trying to figure out
who Snoke was then it was probably ever
going to be worth that said this wasn't
pulled out of nowhere and I think the
issue is because I actually brought this
up in my original review and I must not
have expressed myself properly because
people kind of seemed modeled on what I
was trying to say for me it's a problem
at this point that we don't have answers
on Snoke but I don't feel that it's a
problem that when in the original
trilogy we didn't have answers on the
emperor because we didn't need them and
there's kind of a real key difference
here which is that they may they gave us
just a little bit too much information
about Snoke the Emperor honestly in the
original trilogy we knew almost nothing
about we didn't even know the guys name
we knew nothing about him we I mean for
all we know he wasn't even the first
emperor he could have been the second
the Emperor could have been founded by
somebody else we didn't know it didn't
matter within the context of that first
film and there was no amount of
information that we were given that
really begged answering I mean the okay
this guy's ruling the Empire you can
find we can find out how we got there
eventually we did it wasn't very
interesting but you can find all that
stuff out but nothing about that
original series of films episodes 4 5 &
6 demands answers to it but with Snoke
there's one I and I know this is gonna
seem nitpicky but I'm sorry I'm not
gonna let this go there's one specific
detail that we are given in relation to
Snoke that was not only hinted at in the
force awakens is reaffirmed in the last
Jedi which means they didn't just bring
it up once they brought it up twice in
two movies and this is the reason why I
don't think it's okay to kill him off
and give us no answers in the way that
they did and that is it is stated now in
two separate films that it was Snoke who
turned kylo Ren to the dark side Luke's
war
in the last Jedi war Snoke had already
turned his heart by the time you know
Luke started to recognize the darkness
in him that is one detail to many
because that detail raises a ton of
questions not only about snow king kylo
Ren but about Luke because if you're
saying that that Snoke is the reason
kylo Ren turn to the dark side then how
did he ever get to it I mean if he was
true if he was off training with Luke
when and how did this guy ever get to
him like it raises I mean that's just
the main question that it raises but it
raises a ton of other questions as well
did Luke know about this guy and it the
way he tells the story seems to imply
that he did that one little nugget
raises way too many questions to be
ignored if it had simply been a matter
of he saw darkness and kylo Ren and they
simply apply that once he turned to the
darkness he gravitated towards dark
forces basically implying that kylo Ren
went dark on his own and then found
Snoke after that would have been fine I
need no more information about that
because exactly how they got in touch
with each other doesn't matter but if
the reason kylo Ren is is dark is in
with the dark side of the force is
because of this guy and that's what the
movies have said pretty blatantly then
that is too big a question to not
address and there's another thing beyond
that even if I accept that I am also
getting overly hung up on this cuz
admittedly I'm focusing on this one
detail but again it's a detail brought
up in both movies not just one of them
but even if I set that aside I'm puzzled
by the way in which Disney and Lucasfilm
basically chose to not handle and manage
the fans because if we were never going
to get answers on Snoke or failing that
if it was decided during the making of
the last Jedi that you know what we
could have done answers but we're not
going to because we feel it's
distracting from what we actually want
to do whether it was always the plan to
never give answers or was the decision
made later it doesn't matter
in either case how could they look at
two solid years of a rampant fervent
theorizing and speculation around this
character that just builds up his
importance more and more and more and
nobody involved went huh you know guys
if we're just gonna toss this guy aside
and and have the narrative basically say
he doesn't matter people might get
ticked off because they're making a big
deal out of him like how do you not
address that in some fashion because
look and and how I don't know how I
don't know if you have one of the
directors come out or Kathleen Kennedy
come out and say guys Snoke doesn't
matter so much and I mean I understand
that what suck out the fun but like how
do you do nothing how do you stand back
watch the hype machine go completely out
of your hands and go in an insane
direction that you are not gonna fulfill
and in fact you're creating a movie that
in many ways kind of thumbs its nose at
this entire thing how do you just let
that happen how do you let that train
just get that far away from you you go
ah you know what I'm sure it'll be fine
you leave fans to our own devices and we
will construct this entire you know next
movie that we want and then if you fail
to deliver it we will get upset now is
that the fault of the movie no that's
kind of fan culture we tend to do that a
bit but it's just really weird to me
that a franchise and a company you know
Star Wars as a franchise has managed by
Lucasfilm and Disney as a General
Corporation has a pretty strong track
record at keeping of its finger on the
pulse of their fans and keeping their
expectations in check just didn't bother
trying to do that in this case and
someone on a similar note is Rey and the
whole thing with Rey's parents are
nobody now I am on record even before
the force awakens came out like its
first trailers saying I didn't want
to be anybody I never wanted her to be
anybody I always wanted her to just be a
new force user in my mind there is no
reason for her to be related to a sky
Skywalkers Kenobi's whoever like i it's
it's frustrating to me when people are
like only the Skywalker's can be this
powerful it's it's weird and it's kind
of elitist and it's a it's a mentality
that I'm like I don't why why must it be
that way so you know it's it's a notion
that I like I like the fact that she is
not related to anybody and she is just
she is just strong with the force that
happens sometimes that's effectively
what happened with Anakin whether you
buy into the Immaculate Conception thing
or not he was nobody
before he just exhibited all these
forest powers so again I don't totally
get where the hang-ups on that on the
conceptual level are on the execution
level however there are problems because
much like Snoke if the idea was to
always have it be that she was nobody
then it was a really poor decision to
set up very blatant mysteries around her
in the film and I think much more so
than Snoke who I think you can be more
valid in arguing it didn't really build
any mysteries there was a round ray
there was a lot of blatant hinting and
obscuring of who her parents were who
she might be everyone's asking these
questions who's this girl the film
itself is making a deal out of this and
to then turn around after again two
years worth of rampant speculation to go
she's nobody
again I like that as a premise but how
do you not realize you are gonna tick
off a whole bunch of people doing it
that way
and I even say that recognizing that
it's part of raised journey that she
kind of is in denial about the fact that
she is nobody and she wants to she
wants to become part of the legend of
this universe and in her mind the only
way she can be that as if she is somehow
related to people who are already the
legends in this universe I get that as a
function of her character and her growth
and her development but I still think
it's a bad way to do I think they needed
to just plant their flag in this in
episode 7 and go look she's not related
to anybody
she's just strong with the force the
force has awakened in her that's the
name of the movie deal with it instead
by doing all these hints that maybe
there's something about her about her
passing her history and then for
everyone involved to spend the last two
years Fanning the flame by not dousing
it if nothing else of course people are
ticked off about that even beyond you
know whether or not they have a
fundamental issue with that concept
which again I don't but I don't think
this was a smart way to execute that and
in many ways you can feel the fact that
this is not an over all planned out
trilogy that JJ Abrams made a film with
strands to be picked up later Rian
Johnson came in and made a film about
what he wanted to do and I don't have an
inherent problem with that way of making
a film except that this is a series that
has had you know in the in the various
trilogies that it's had that it can be
broken into episodes 1 2 3 episodes 4 5
6 there is a through line and you can
see where things are going and I mean
George Lucas likes to build up his own
myth about how much of 5 & 6 were
already planned when he did the original
Star Wars and I I don't think it's
nearly as playing out as he likes to
make it look but at the very least
things were weren't as jarring ly
feeling like they were like just veering
off from where things started and that's
the thing I think if this movie had been
episode 7 and I don't mean like plot
stark they're like oh we just don't do
that but like in terms of the themes in
terms of what it's doing the turn in the
way in which it is a very different Star
Wars movie if this had been episode 7 I
think we'd be having a very different
conversation there
still be people ticked off at it I have
no doubt but the difference would be
you'd be kicking off a new trilogy by
going this is how this is different from
all the other Star Wars that came before
instead what they did they kicked off
the new trilogy with a film that was
soaked in nostalgia for the original
trilogy so you kick off this new trilogy
by going look how much we're like old
Star Wars and then you continue it by
going we are not like old Star Wars and
that that in my mind is kind of cruel to
your audience because I think there's a
whole chunk of Star Wars fandom that
went into the force awakens and they may
not have been happy about it but if they
got something more along the lines of
the last Jedi they just would have gone
okay you know what this new trilogy is
not being made for me I'm gonna walk
away I've got my original stuff new fans
and other people they can have this new
trilogy but instead they give such a
huge chunk of the old fanbase exactly
what they've always been clamoring for
and then with the very next follow-up
seem to go out of their way to
deconstruct all the stuff that they love
and again that that makes for an okay
movie in and of itself but in terms of
an overall thing of course there's a
backlash I mean and that's and again
that's the thing that's what I mean when
I say its place in the franchise as a
whole if this if this happened the start
of the new trilogy you would have set
the tone for that but this is not
consistent with the tone that the force
awakens set it feels incredibly
disjointed it really truly does feel
like Rian Johnson came in looked at what
JJ Abrams had done and just didn't want
to do what he did and went in another
way in many ways actually honestly it
reminded me of the Justice League movie
because the Justice League movie just
flat-out ignored or dropped or hand
waved away so much stuff that was set up
in Batman V Superman but there it made
sense because so many people didn't like
Batman V Superman they were like okay
well we're not gonna continue with that
through-line because people weren't
liking it we're going in a new direction
because that one wasn't working by and
large people liked the force awakens I
know it's like a we're
the popular thing now to act like being
wolves are really that great eye but by
and large people like the force awakens
and - - coming off of something that
people liked and accept it and we're
excited for the next thing and - to just
go yeah there's all this stuff in it
that I don't want to deal with I'm doing
something else just seems really weird
to me and and doubly so when you take
into account that these are not the only
Star Wars movies we get if you want to
go in a completely different direction
and explore completely new themes in
Star Wars especially after you've
already established with the start of
your new trilogy how much you're honing
in on along the vibe of the originals
why are you doing it in the main series
instead of doing it in one of the
spin-offs and if you're not gonna go in
completely new directions than the
spin-offs what's the point of the side
stories and the spin-offs and that's why
like I don't know how to feel at this
point about the fact that Rian Johnson
is gonna do three Star Wars movies as a
complete separate og I think I'm kind of
of the mind of I wish they just hired
him and had him done that from the
get-go and didn't have him do Episode
eight because there is a lot of
deconstruction in Episode eight and
deconstruction is not in and of itself a
bad thing in fact some of the best most
potent stories can be deconstruction of
stories but to make a comparison of some
of the really great deconstructionist
stories from say comic books that would
be things like Watchmen The Dark Knight
Returns Superman red Sun but there's a
key thing with all three of those
they're all Elseworlds
or possible futures or otherwise not
part of the main continuity
I don't think deconstruction works when
you make it part of the main story
especially if you're expecting to
continue that story on after you've done
it you when you deconstruct something by
its nature you take it apart and you
break it so why would you do that in the
main series when you have the ability to
do these kind of deconstructionist
elements and you know poke at the
legends of the Jedi and how valid they
are or aren't or whatever else you have
more
to do that in other ways to do it in
other films I just I don't understand
why it's part of the main series here
and beyond that if they're going to do
that I don't understand why everyone
seems so shocked that so many fans are
back lashing on this and that's kind of
my main thing there are other things
that I can that I could talk about I'll
just touch on briefly mostly to say why
I'm not going to talk about them more
people talking about Luke being out of
character depends on how you want to
define Luke's character because speaking
of someone who loves the movies the
original trilogy at the very least but
never got into expanded universe or any
of that Luke's character is actually
pretty consistent with how he was in the
movies because Luke's entire arc in
those first three movies was basically
him continuously edging up to the two
right at the precipice of going dark
even dipping his toe into it and then
pivoting back and I don't see how him
just firing up his lightsaber but
immediately thinking oh god no what am i
doing and not going through with it
is any different than the other times
that he stepped into darkness and came
back however if you are really attached
to the expanded universe stuff that has
been done with Luke that's where it
becomes inconsistent and again this
factors into what I said before which is
that when you look at the film within
the context of this franchise that's
where a lot of these problems happen now
a lot of people have built up their
image of what Luke should be like at
this age based on a lot of expanded
universe stuff that had gone on and
built a very specific image of older
Jedi Master Luke and this is not that
now again is that necessarily fair to
the movie should it be beholden to what
was done in something that they
deliberately declared is no longer canon
no not necessarily but at the same time
if you're gonna go against that when you
know it's ingrained in the fan culture
even though you told them - please -
please not pay attention to it you can't
be shocked when a chunk of your audience
says no you got it wrong another common
complaint seems to be the humor in the
film for me the humor was fine if I were
to pinpoint the thing because it
initially struck me as odd because you
go back and watch the original Star Wars
actually a lot of humor in that I mean
mean lines like little short for a
stormtrooper somebody got this big
walking carpet out of my way there was a
boring conversation anyway those are
funny lines and there's quite a few of
them I think the difference though might
be is that in the and the original films
or at the very least that are that first
film that I just cited those jokes are
line set by characters and reactions to
situation they're not setup punchline
and I think a little bit more of the
humor in the last Jedi feels setup
punchline which is a different kind of
humor to one snarky line because of the
situation we're in so maybe that's the
issue there one thing I'm not gonna
dwell on though is lay up because I know
a lot of people it seems like almost
everybody hates the Leia in space moment
I don't I love it I seem to be one of
our only a handful of people who love it
and more to the point so far as I can
tell I'm the only person who loves that
moment but does not like the film
overall I seem to be the only one in
that particular camp but I it's fine I
thought it was a wonderful triumphant
moment if you want to make the argument
to me that visually it looks a little
goofy I don't agree but you know what I
that's I'll give a certain amount of
merit to that if the emotion didn't
connect with you yeah okay maybe it
looks a little off the whole thing about
she shouldn't be able to do that that
makes no sense to me because we already
know she's force sensitive and what
she's doing is such a basic thing don't
give me like she hasn't been trained
Luke had his lightsaber come to his hand
at the start of the Empire Strikes Back
in the Whomper cave he had never been
trained on how to do that really the
only training he gotten at that point
from obi-wan was the vaguest sense of
stretch out with your feelings and how
to hold a lightsaber so he didn't kill
himself that was it but he still was
able to do that so I don't see why it's
such a leap that Leia should be able to
pull herself towards the ship I I don't
agree that that's an issue again if you
have an issue with that you think the
visual was just goofy again don't agree
but that's harder for me to argue with
so I think I'm done I intended to kind
of build you a grandeur point but I
think I ended up making my point more
like 2/3 of the way in and then just
tacking on a few additional things that
the
and honestly I'm just trying to expunge
this thing I want to stop thinking about
this movie and I'm hoping that in doing
this video I'll have gotten enough of my
thoughts out there clarified some of the
stuff that I said before responded to
some of the stuff that I've seen said
and gone on since then that I can kind
of be done talking about this movie for
a while and again before anybody asks
maybe I'll watch it again and maybe I
will think different of it on a rewatch
right now I'm not planning to because I
don't want to and that does make a
difference because you know to cite some
other movies that I was either uncertain
or kind of iffy on but liked much better
on the second watch Wonder Woman the
flaws seem much smaller to me second
time I watch that guardians the galaxy
the few wishes I had seemed way more
mine a second time I watched it held the
force awakens I wasn't sure what I
thought of it coming out of the theater
but I woke up the next day going no I
really like this this one I just don't
want to watch it again not right now
anyways and I definitely just want to
stop thinking about it
so that'll wrap it up for this one and
hopefully hopefully it'll be the last
time I have to talk about Star Wars for
a while so that's it for me folks what
are your current thoughts on not just
the movie but the backlash responses to
the backlash etc etc keep it respectful
please whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it like subscribe all the
stuff I'm on twitter at council of geeks
i have a podcast the council of geeks
podcast apple podcast and stitcher radio
I'm also 1/2 of the punch like a girl
podcast that's on the fire and water
podcast network Fire and Water podcast
calm until next time this council is
adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]